at the mouth of the river plate' lies
Montevideo Uruguay's capital monumental
buildings commemorate an economic boom
the country experienced during the
second world war it seems almost as if
time has Stood Still
ever since globalization has yet to
reach this corner of the globe
at every turn one finds the horse-drawn
carts of the garbage Pickers known here
as cartoneros at last count there were
about 16,000 in the city
Mario supports his family by collecting
and sorting trash I have seven children
at home
the littlest is five months old the
biggest is 12 years so I have to get out
and earn the money I married very young
he has no training or skills you can't
find any real jobs these days they're
always looking for people with
experience in construction not just
helping hands I've worked as a builder I
kept dick wells make cement that I can't
put a wall I don't know how
recycling is one possibility for people
to make a living who can't find any
other job where opportunities are so
limited have year is 15 and horsey is 16
I'm collecting food for our pig will
sort rate at the next holiday and have a
good time we're also looking for food
for our horse we sell the boxes and
bottles we keep a little money for
ourselves and give the rest to the
family
we're on the road from 8:00 in the
evening till morning and we go out again
from 12 noon till 6 you work the whole
night through yes all night and then
again during the day we make 2 rounds
every day don't want to do something
else me too I don't want to spend my
whole life on the horse cart what can
you do without education I don't know
something
Zuka see no idea maybe I'll work in
construction
I want to be a baker but I've never
learned how I guess I'll have to
Oh United
most of the cartoon arrows live on the
city's outskirts where they store their
pickings until they sell them to a
recycling dealer
urease has made enough from garbage to
get ahead just a bit he's retired his
old horse and cart I've been working the
streets for 30 years with its old mayor
and now I've got a truck now Lewis has a
little recycling operation of his own
with a truck and four young employees
looking for something I can pick up
they're gonna get my people and we
recycle everything copper brass aluminum
we sell the scrap and spare parts I
process it and sell it
Louise has learned to derive the maximum
value from every resource including from
his truck this is a 1956 Opel with the
original motor he's been on the road for
54 years the truck is a collector's item
Louise has found a kind of philosopher's
stone a way to turn junk into gold this
is real gold you scrape it off with a
sander it fetches a thousand pesos a
kilo now you see how my business works
is my Albert Allah grew up in Sweden
this is my friend his parents returned
to Uruguay after the years of military
rule here you find your place here are
more like me they communicate through
the same codes economically it's hard to
hear people have to work a lot more but
incredible things happen can don't be
for instance you meet people and form a
group without any kind of business
interests getting in the way and that's
much more human every weekend is my Al
and his group performed Camden Bay a
kind of music and dance that African
slaves brought to Uruguay in the 18th
century long the exclusive province of
the afro Uruguayans today people of
every color and class play kendama the
street culture has become part of the
country's heritage
shopper ominous simply to be sucking up
I always used to think there was no
racism here but there is yin see if toys
but in candombe a black and white people
play together I'm friends with a bunch
of people who never even think about
anything like that
no I finally over which brings us
together in together
NOP insanity
at the weekend people all over
Montevideo dance and drum can dombay
preparations for Carnaval go all
year-round
traditionally Uruguay's economy has been
an agricultural one founded on the
estancia's or ranches marcelo Fossati is
an agronomist he advises farmers on
growing organic produce he drops by to
see the Montenegro family lindahl fo
Montenegro co-founded the seed Network
to collect and preserve domestic crop
species it started with a handful of
farmers and today numbers over a hundred
this is the seed bank seeds of wheat
vegetables and their bulbs it's a
dynamic Bank a collective one the
domestic species have to adapt
continuously so we can maintain them so
it's important for the seed bank to be
out here where the farmers are the other
side that's your name yes it's important
so the farmers don't vanish either this
region has already lost most of its
small holders family farms no longer pay
here the Montenegro family is an
exception we're looking at a fairly
privileged piece of ground we're pretty
isolated here so we don't have any big
problems with contamination from the
soybean farms
a few kilometers away a field has been
prepared for planting genetically
modified soybeans herbicide has been
applied to kill off unwanted plants the
weeds the soybeans have been modified to
make them resistant but the poison seeps
into the groundwater cuatro Cinco ISA
here in Uruguay there were four or five
corporations specialized in GM crops
they don't buy land they lease it and
they're not interested in what happens
to the land in the future they use it
for three or four years then when
nothing grows on it anymore when all
that's left is desert they move on at
least someplace else
and when all Latin America's natural
resources have been exhausted someday
they'll go on to Africa or someplace and
do the same but eventually they'll have
to go to another planet because we won't
be able to grow anything on earth
anymore porque Senora KRT even on the
world with you are four decades Lindo
sir Montenegro has been developing
several varieties of seed grain that he
uses on his own farm and distributes to
other organic farmers as well
now though he worries that his plants
will be contaminated by the genetically
modified ones
the danger is especially high for corn
is it my colleague or citizen if the
corn is contaminated it will also become
transgenic and that automatically makes
it the property of the seed corporation
that owns the rights to the modified
gene then not only can they take the
farmers corn crop away from him
the corn he's been planting forever they
can make him pay to keep on using it if
the produce is a summation marcelo
Fossati ends the day with a visit to
friends who grow medicinal herbs and
plants
they are also part of the ever-growing
seed network of small farmers who are
making a stand against the agro
corporations we cross the border into
southern Brazil
the state of hyo gran je de su has
attracted immigrants from all parts of
europe many of them were fleeing hunger
poverty or war starting in the mid-1800s
many Germans settled in the region
around the town of gramado today Gramado
is attracting tourists with its exotic
storybook Germany image of black forest
houses Wurst and folk dances
the German house of youth keeps up old
traditions Gerhardt Kleiner's father
started the house of youth in the late
1950s theater father art boy in the
bunkers done that there was a bank
standing on this spot from here my
father and mother and brothers and
sisters and I looked over there
discovered the piece of ground for the
house of youth
now Gerhardt Kleiner's son dieter has
taken over as director of the house of
youth he also organizes the German folk
dances in the region over 60 groups just
in the region around gramado
I know that's infested sorrows on the
one hand we're proud of it on the other
we have to decide if it's really such a
good thing in Germany no longer place
much value on German culture I don't
know how much longer we'll be able to
keep it up here in the countryside
around gramado far from the tourist
crowds live the descendants of the 19th
century German immigrants to Brazil
Gerhard kleiner listens to the stories
the oldest generation has to tell of
these immigrants he can save them for
posterity every settler received a grant
of 25 hectares enough to make a good
living some of the small family farms
remain worked by father and son and
mother and daughter
constantly you'll never make it to
Germany it's too far away cost too much
as well if I were rich I don't have a
look but I can't they're Huns rook
dialect from the Moselle Valley has
become established here even though most
of the settlers came from Pomerania on
the other side of Germany they distill
their own snaps and make their own worst
just like their ancestors from Pomerania
did the current generation is the eighth
since the time of settlement they remain
largely isolated from the rest of Brazil
your voices David I touched anything
about anger Valentin we Germans both
ethnic and immigrant have integrated
here as Brazilians even though we speak
German and keep up German customs and
traditions and cultivate our German se
is very proud of it but even so we're
Brazilians first
from gramado we continue on to Rio de
Janeiro
to the rest of the world Rio evokes
images of the beaches of Ipanema
and the Copacabana of samba and soccer
but this city has many sides and many
problems that it has to deal with before
the 2014 FIFA World Cup or the 2016
Olympic Games
seventeen-year-old barbara lee our CEO
is a 200-meter sprinter and a star in
Rio and the rest of Brazil she was the
face of the campaign that eventually won
the Olympic Games for Rio de Janeiro I
think sports should get more support
especially here in Brazil the government
should invest in it seriously it has to
help us create the appropriate
conditions for 2016 Fabian will be able
to achieve some really good performances
Barbara comes from a poor backgrounds
like everyone here her coach Paolo servo
has made it his personal mission to give
disadvantaged young people opportunities
through sports after training Paolo
invites the athletes home with him for
dinner to make sure they get the
necessary nutrients how can kids who
don't eat properly go in for sports
it isn't easy so I opened the kitchen
here first we only served one meal a day
but now we're fixing breakfast lunch and
dinner all the kids who come to us
barbara was undernourished she weighed
eight kilos under the normal range for
her age today she's a very determined
person very disciplined
it's an example but she had a really
hard time at first yeah yellow is help
for me what we can after dinner Paulo
drives Barbara to the jaw of a large
Olympic Stadium for an interview for a
sports magazine from Spain
how low has taken Barbara wherever she
needed to go and protected and helped
her since she was a child both in her
private life and her athletic career
early Madonna he's always helped me
right from the start it was very
important for my life in the poor
neighborhoods where we live the kids are
totally delighted with the practice even
e-sports gives them an opportunity to
change their lives he changed my life
too I think it's wonderful that Paulo
goes straight to the children in the
schools he tells me he can't do this
forever
and I've told him I'll take his place
and look after the kids we've done less
videos Barbara would have liked to
practice here for the Olympics but the
stadium is leased to a soccer club
I think they should open the stadium to
all the athletes it's the best track in
a real we'd really like very much to
practice here get him today nikkor pitch
a key even if a cracked bumpy track is
all she'll ever have to practice on
Barbara still has her dream of an
Olympic medal and she's determined to
achieve it
dona marta is one of rio de janeiro's
hundreds of favelas but it's a slum with
a difference dona marta is the only
favela with its own cable car many other
things have changed here in recent years
- even when Dean sees Dona Marta as a
kind of model for vaillar
el mapa morning I hear lecture by Mitch
peak it's a relatively small community
wedged into the heart of the southern
zone it practically has natural
geographical limits in form of the
forest preserves and the clips and in a
way that made it easier to test this
kind of model here it's more than yo
it's got its own cable car its houses
have been rehabbed and massive police
raids have pushed out it's drug dealers
perhaps most importantly the police have
stayed on in the favela and maintained
good relations with its residents a
concrete wall prevents the favelas
expansion into the adjacent Nature
Preserve Dona Marta has been serving as
one big laboratory for this new form of
assistance from the state which provides
a technical school a medical facility
and daycare center and a special unit of
peacemaker police this experience has
been very productive once it's been
evaluated this could mean a massive
change for Rio de Janeiro they wash
Karen Saeed Abedini many of Dona Marta's
residents are still waiting for that
change to reach their doorsteps among
them hos Angela and her four children
they barely scrape by in their tiny
Shack here are two of my children
the other two are out in the street I
can't live in the streets with my four
children I want a better place to finish
raising them the wealth of the common
people is there children
the musician Pierre Avila has been
working in the favela for many years now
he started a music school here
Pierre says it's not enough to drive out
the drug dealers the only thing that
will have any lasting effect is to
create opportunities for the young
people it's the only hope they have of
breaking out of the vicious cycle of
poverty drugs violence and unemployment
if you give them a chance you'll see
that many young people are willing to
work willing to help build Donna Mota
thanks to these new policies so it's a
question of opportunity and cultural
development now these kids have a music
school a soccer club and they're not
running with the armed gangs anymore
Christ died where did the pilgrims find
shelter in Martha's house this mountain
has the geographical name Dona Marta but
we prefer to call the neighborhood Santa
Marta that better expresses the pacifism
and hospitality of the people here last
year we wrote a song it goes Santa Marta
my life my passion my story my home
hope for a better life has returned to
Rio de Janeiro's favelas
in the next part of our series we turn
back South to Ciudad del Este in
Paraguay